[Music]
watch your last night at me if you
notice a record was set last night Mad
Men set a record by losing all 17
categories in which they were nominated
nominated in some team lost all 17 on
but people were stunned yeah
even worse all 17 of them were won by
here comes honey boo boo
why were they in the same category baby
have you seen here comes honey boo yeah
there's haradrim and there's more
drinking and smoking in honey boo boo
yeah yeah it's a true story let's talk
about LA for a second this weekend is
big Los Angeles is shutting down a major
freeway for what they're calling
Carmageddon - yeah officials are trying
to keep everyone off the streets this
weekend by announcing that Lindsay Lowen
is out for a drive
everyone's gonna be in the bushes
peeking out hiding in pickle barrel's
old school they tell us pickle barrel's
I just pictured it very old-timey you
know people running and chop comes up
yeah it's on their head they look around
and they go back down Rick Perry in the
news a new book claims that Texas
Governor Rick Perry did not win the
Republican primary because he suffers
from a sleep disorder and that was the
reason he yeah his his doctor said also
not helping he's dumb as a rock
my kids doctor lived in the charts oh
yeah he's stupid yeah it says right here
you're dumb yeah
any football fans here are you betcha
people heat clap for that even if
they're not right Ryan's it's rare the
person is like no well at the at the New
England Patriots game on if he saw this
coach Bill Belichick was so mad about a
call by the replacement referees he
grabbed a refs arm yeah
fortunately Belichick was quickly
stopped by the referees seeing-eye dog
winner Dean
[Applause]
[Music]
by the way I'm from Boston sauce a
little bitter about that crazy story in
China follow me on this in China a
factory that makes iPhones had to be
shut down after 2000 workers 2,000
workers got into a brawl
yeah the brawl was captured on 10000
iPhones they were just the most how do
2,000 people get into a fight I don't
know I have no idea ever seen a kung fu
movie backing each other crazy story
folks it comes out it's come out comes
out it's Monday I bet a lot of money on
Mad Men and I'm better it come out
[Applause]
[Music]
try it's been reported
[Applause]
it's been reported that a chemical in
the McRib is also used to make yoga mats
yeah also this marks the first time that
yoga and McRib have mentioned the same
[Applause]
sentence no one finishes a bucket of
mcribs and then like let's get into
downward dog well I was gonna say for me
personally it explains why yoga mats are
so delicious I've been kicked out every
yoga place in this sit-down
whenever I see Andy walking this yoga
mat has a big chomp out of it is that
you walking with your yoga mat it's not
a fruit roll-up
[Laughter]